aiuto non ci vediamo niente allora oggi
andiamo a fare una nuova challenge
allora siccome siamo resi conto che ci
sono degli sconti online già bene regali
di natale prima deciso di farsi un
regalo di natale ha senso che
risparmiamo un pochino al diane pratica
andremo a fare shopping bendati e
andremo a votare per risparmiare un
pochino allora ci siamo inventati
andremo a comprare i nostri regali di
natale o il nostro regalo di natale
dovevo decidere conti prete che facciamo
1 2 2 2 2 2 4
sono però dobbiamo stare attenti a non
prendere le cose super costose come
facciamo stare attenti perde altri
facciamo shopping bendati e lo show di
un bel laiche a 10.000 l'ice andremo
farne un altro vede pronti perché avete
due band dobbiamo decidere chi sarà
questo challenge comprerà le cose perché
l'altra persona deve controllare che
stiamo cliccando da qualche parte
altrimenti siamo tutti e due bendati
cliccheremo da nessuna parte
quindi facciamo carta morbi se stesso
per decidere chi sara bendata era carica
e mezzo da carta forbice 61 carta
forbice sasso
ok portici e tasse avrà l'onore di
cliccare io sono quella che si dispera
perché ci siamo siamo nella nostra lista
desideri per i nostri regali di natale
per un bene ok poi iniziare questo mouse
si cosa sembra certa cosa sto facendo
ma è il punto toto siamo nella lista
desideri
ok adesso posso scendere poi vari
proprio voi e stigliano di conto di
niente è immobile su come far bene in
calando grande sta scendendo giorno si
sta girovagando tra gli oggetti ce ne
sono alcuni troppo costosi alcun vero ti
aiuto no oddio io resto dove andare non
sono non avendo ben vedendo dove sto
andando non riesco a capire se sto
scarse sto scendendo giù perché stai
scendendo piano piano stiamo vedendo
tutte le cose più costose e meno costose
che cos'era quella lui andiamo a
riprenderla uffici clicchiamo sopra suo
ha quindi sto andando al contrario non
aspetta quindi adesso è tutto solo si sa
se faccio così è tutto se mi faccio così
facendo si che cosa senti già i sei
attratto dal costo è quello è una cosa
che abbiamo viggiano e ce l'avete invece
il mio bellissimo libro forti vabbè
tanto ce l'abbiamo già allora sì deciso
inter e cliccare su qualcosa che non
riesco non riesco a capire se ti stai
muovendo che quindi stai continuando ad
andare in su niente niente evitare ad
esito di tiro mandare le sicuro
attenzione clicca perché non si è aperto
bene replica ho cliccato
clicca se ho cliccato ok ok abbiamo già
abbiamo già un qualcosa per fortuna dopo
ben non dico niente aspetta per la
giungla carrella lo so pero che con la
prima volta che lo faccio bendato quindi
non vi dà la funzione se no io bendata
ora sai cosa si prova a non sapere dove
per elaborare paura di prendere o che il
primo oggetto ce l'abbiamo e poi non
riesco a capire cosa non li serve che fa
capire se sto andando su 1 giu non ho
una concezione quindi infatti a volte
stai fermo comunque il primo ce
l'abbiamo
ma cosa ha visto comunque volevo anche
recentemente quindi sono contenta sto
andando giù adesso che non riesco a
capire si sta difendendo oddio no però
non hai cliccato so niente no ancora
niente diciamo che ti sei vicino aspetta
si è aperta una cosa strana
aggiungi un commento aiuto qui sei quasi
nella pagina di quasi anche fatto no
ancora non hai cliccato i miei è male
nel vuoto
boh non so dove andare sui topi e io non
devo dire niente
no sky ha perso la barra de bè allora si
è aperta una pagina così prima lusso
perché non apre comunque per certo si è
una costanza questo corso però vabbè se
il nostro regalo di natale cliccato
direi che ci fermiamo qua altrimenti
finisce male molto molto male perché
tanto paghi due
basta non posso più ok quindi vanno bene
premiamo sì ora procedo all'ordine
quindi dovremmo avere con la band dover
correggere la verità per il niente io
saprò cosa ricevi avuto il regalo di
natale ma tu non lo saprai remoto con la
band amici tutti poi la volta che arrivo
lo potrete dire la band ha quindi ora
procedo a fare l'ordine euro se poi ci
rivediamo una volta che arrivano i
regali 32 euro
il moto indossano cocco che ci sono
anche le decorazioni dell'albero è
curioso che cosa presa come vedere tutte
anni hai fatto allora tu quel che
racconta alla volta senza vedere cosa e
così una volta saranno sorpresa offriamo
al gate
così se ti scappa 20 pagine persona poi
così può essere che va di qualcun altro
quindi meglio che taglio qualcun altro
piuttosto che dagli dei che iniziamo per
la prima cosa posso fare io me lo
ricordo da bambino questa prima c'era la
pubblicità in tv che facevamo prima la
bocca di rosa o riso nel corpo 20 st e
mai giocato non sono fuori volta in
gioco per dentisti coraggiosi
tra l'altro sono stessi istanti di
giocare o poco del città o a dottor
trapani non sapere percorre i fatti
commessi nella lista desideri fate si
sta bene se volete che prendiamo anche
tutto il trapano semmai perché ci
giochiamo insieme in un video qui ci
sono le regole è grande stavolta a
mangiare un pezzo di cappone
chi sono chi ha dovuto informare il
cocco caprino importiamo gli occhi
queste sono il naso gli occhi non essere
incollato con obiettivo allora vediamo
vorrei ok perfetto perché vorrei dire di
messaggi degli occhi st calaio di bantry
chi è allora il primo occhio qui come a
canzo di cazzo non ricordo male le
faceva dire altri con la bocca ti darò
il sorriso solo e coco dentista sapere
ancora la pubblicità ma che ne hanno
cambiato canzoni e culturale nostra
società sembra pronto a mangiarsi le
dita
allora lasciate online che se volete che
giochiamo a colpo dentista in un video
magari aggiungiamo qualche qualche
regola particolare tipo devi mettere
dentro gli ingredienti slime quando
chiude devi utilizzarli
fatemi sapere insomma le vostre idee per
cocco dentista poco dentista ma cambiamo
a catena anche quella bocca di un
sorriso dopo il colpo dentista con lo so
se c'è ancora se è così
passiamo all'altro oggetto che è stato
la mia rovina anche grassi quando
costava questo è solo non mi sono mai il
prossimo era quello che costavano in più
non volevo la curiosità di toccare il
terzo del pil di 3 marcato come
bassolino patrizia sai cosa
queste secondo set la scatola è
bellissimo dai è bellissima la scatola
city e pesaro
c'ero anch'io perché non ho mai avuto
una console grande quando ero in video
la boy color eight game boy advance non
ho mai avuto nessuna console consumi
l'incremento primo passo 96 ovvio dietro
la strage giocatore di poter piquet dei
pokémon pokémon cosa cellulare di tanto
in tanto ma questo momento è uguale
fatemi sapere se questa prete cos'è nei
commessi in pratica e pokémon let's
colour el'edizione specie di internet
crisi dentro
l'edizione speciale pokémon infatti
nello squizzi si sono pikachu e ivi
sopra anche i joystick sono uno color
picazio quindi giallo e marrone con è
uno colore il marroncino bianco e poi
dentro c'è anche la poké ball che può
essere usata come joystick come poche
bolle ti regalano anche un pokémon che
uno dei più rari di sempre che mio che è
uno dei miei potevo il prete
il remake moderno di pokemon il giallo e
io da piccola il primo gioco il popolo a
cui ho giocato al pokémon donna cra blu
o rosso in che ce l'avevano prestato
quindi non hanno il tempo di godermelo
viene a giocare molto bene o poi
poi mio padre mi regalò pokemon crystal
non so se qualcuno di voi se lo ricorda
e sa perché voi infancy se non sbaglio e
pokemon cristallo conosco a memoria
perché l'ho fatto giocate rigiocata tipo
25 volte vedo l'ora pochissimi la
schedina
detto questo giallo con loro bianco no è
no
lunedì toccherà pokémon gialle c'era
applicazione l'ha governata da nove in
blu c'era mio passato il nome di mente
io pronto a tutti i rovi dei pokémon non
mi viene in mente come si chiama 4
essere vitale fano invitano un altro
youtube r che stavo urlato queste cose e
mi viene bla stories ma non mi ricordo
invece poco
stasera charman in pokémon cristalli
c'era uno dei pokémon rari che poi il
cambio il nome è un milan e celeste dote
vista perché volevo ricordate comunque
stato troppo emozionata se volete
facciamo dei gameplay in cui giochiamo
un pokémon in entrambi per vita sarà
un'esperienza nuova
quindi potrete vedere una persona che è
stato per la prima volta che non conosce
il pokémon dai fan culo con ossi se la
prima la prima edizione di pokemon
gobelin napoli c'è un po visto che ci
sono le evoluzioni adesso l'uccello male
non si sono sempre fatte meglio io che
sono già giocare ho visto che c'è una
modalità per giocare con due giochi in
due però non so come funzionava bene
vedremo assieme dobbiamo sperimentare
fateci sapere se volete che
il gameplay in cui giochiamo insieme ai
modelli del canale di vitale quindi non
vi confondete nel mio canale con
videogiochi sono davvero dei commenti
siccome questo video è troppo lungo
l'unboxing di questo ve lo lascio nel
canale digitale quindi cliccate capa
cliccate per vedere l'unboxing di questo
in cui andiamo a vedere le poche ball
joystick tutto quando indicate
quantificate cliccate qua e noi ci
vediamo di questo video quindi cliccate
e chissà